President Trump is looking for a new
chief of staff after his top pick
decided against taking the job the
president tweeted last night he'll make
a decision soon on who will replace the
departing John Kelly the retired Marine
general is set to leave by the end of
the month wooja Jang is at the White
House we should good morning good
morning Nora several names are in the
mix to replace Kelly but the former
favorite you're right is not among them
vice president Mike Pence's chief of
staff Nick Ayers was the top contender
but now says he is leaving the
administration at the end of the year
White House sources tell CBS News the
president wanted Ayers to commit through
the 20/20 re-election campaign the 36
year old though was eager to move back
to Georgia to spend time with his young
family but says he will work with the
mega team to advance the cause sources
say Trump short list to replace Kelley
includes North Carolina congressman Mark
Meadows Office of Management and Budget
Director make Mulvaney an acting
Attorney General Matt Whitaker
president Trump has nominated William
Barr to fill the full time AG post State
Department spokesperson Heather Nauert
to serve as ambassador to the United
Nations and army general mark Milley as
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
and with Kelley gone his former mentee
homeland security secretary Kirsten
Nielsen could be the next to go
John we should thank you a lot of chairs
moving in the administration